hi there steve kaufman here uh today i'm
going to talk a bit about learning
japanese because yesterday i did a video
in japanese
so i thought it would be timely to talk
a bit about that
um i'm going to be doing these various
non-english videos
but i'm going to try to maintain twice a
week in english for those of you who
don't understand these various foreign
languages
but i'm hoping that the other you know
japanese whatever
french chinese will attract viewers in
other languages i've always felt and
this is part of my whole attitude
towards creating link is
that uh you know even english language
speakers should learn other languages
and the whole world need not speak
english even though of course english is
very useful
um japanese
i moved to japan in 1971
from hong kong where i had studied
chinese i had the great advantage
in approaching japanese that i already
could read the characters
so the first thing about learning
japanese is that if you want to read
you're going to have to learn the
characters you're not going to be able
to read very much just with hiragana
let's take step back
in japanese there are three writing
systems
hiragana which is used which is a
phonetic script it's based on syllables
each syllable has a symbol and there is
a parallel one called katakana which is
used for
foreign origin words or words that are
sort of sound words you know smash crash
and stuff and then there's characters
you do need the characters
and i believe it's very useful to be
able to read in order to accumulate
sufficient vocabulary to have
intelligent discussions
okay
i went to japan i had the characters
that was a tremendous advantage i
learned japanese and this again there
were questions after my previous video
how long did i spend to learn japanese
how did i do it and so forth
i lived in japan for nine years that's
obviously a tremendous advantage i've
said many times the more you speak the
language the better you get at speaking
it
however uh within one year of arriving
in japan i was conducting business in
japanese giving talks in japanese i was
working at the canadian embassy
um
and uh so i learned it rather quickly i
did it in on my own i didn't go to
school
i didn't have a tutor
i just listened and and read a lot and i
watched tv i used the first i could
understand the baseball games on tv and
eventually i moved from there to
political discussions because again
the newspapers were a little easier to
read because there's more characters
there and what was most difficult of
course was movies and soap operas and
those kinds of things that were on tv
but certainly over the course of the
nine years my japanese improved and i
think this is another important point
you can very quickly arrive at a level
in a language where you can actually
communicate and do stuff
but then to get better and better and
better and better it all takes a long
time
so uh yeah nine years
what did i do okay i read
i i have to admit that i used a lot of
you know i read what i read books that
had
vocabulary lists
rarely did i use
the dictionary because it's very
frustrating it's hard to look things up
and you forget them right away so i used
material that had
a vocabulary list for each lesson
whatever i could find um i went through
all the sort of grammar textbooks if you
want you know lesson one uh you know my
name is mr suzuki lesson two this is my
family lesson three uh at the grocery
store and so
i went through as quickly as possible i
never do exercises as i've said before
and i don't remember any of the
grammatical terms
uh
so
you know i decided to google here
japanese grammar learn japanese and the
resources available today are phenomenal
and if any of you want to start learning
japanese or if you are in the midst of
learning japanese you should certainly
make yourself aware of all the resources
that are out there
there's one
you know i googled japanese grammar the
first thing i got was of course a thing
from wikipedia which is hopeless the
japanese language has a regular
agglutinative verb morphology with both
productive and fixed elements in
language typology it has many features
divergent from most european languages
its phrases are exclusively head final
and compound sentences are exclusively
left branching blah blah
you know if that was my only source i
would quit i wouldn't go beyond that to
me that is hopeless
uh you don't need it to be that
complicated
there's a thing called the
learningpage.com there's kim's guide to
japanese and many more resources find
the one that you like
now
with a lot of these resources especially
take him and the
japanese page i think excellent in that
they provide
uh sort of sample sentences of the
different sort of patterns in japanese
and the japanese page actually has audio
it's actually an excellent resource they
both are i think take him goes into too
much detail
about what can happen and could happen
and stuff you don't really need that but
they're both good and they both have
iphone apps as well
uh i think kay can take kim's is free
and the japanese page is like eight
euros or something but it looks to be
well worth it if i were learning
japanese i would get that app
now how to use these resources you can't
learn a language by just reading all
these isolated phrases so this has to be
done in conjunction with again
a lot of listening and reading
and so you listen and read then you go
back to these resources and a lot at
first it seems overwhelming there are so
many patterns so many things that are
difficult how can i ever learn this but
as
you become familiar with some of these
patterns you start to notice other
patterns so you go back to the you know
you whatever you decide to use as your
resource for how the language works the
different patterns of the language then
you go back to listening and reading you
start to notice it you go back to this
resource so
that's how to go about it
uh briefly on the japanese language
you know the way the japanese language
works is
they have sort of words that act as
punctuation marks in a way you know you
say you know
what actually is i
okay and one of the delights of japanese
is there's various ways of saying i you
and so forth depending on degrees of
politeness but don't worry about it you
get used to it so watashi
is like
i am canadian
canada canada
canadian gin is person another delight
in japanese is jin is also pronounced
so because
japanese borrowed a lot of words from
chinese therefore those words
the same word the same character can
have a pronunciation
which originates from chinese and is
kind of similar to the chinese
pronunciation typically one
syllable
and the original japanese before the
chinese words were imported
pronunciation so
and
the end of the sentence in japanese is
always very important that's where
things happen
let's put the question mark at the end
so that's very basic
and if you're not a canadian you say
watakshiva canada
now here's where again
it was this right canada
that's the long way of saying no
or you can say
dewa contracts to ja
and arimasen which is negative arimas is
not but instead of saying
you can say
so again not to overwhelm you but it's
just to recognize that there are often
simplified ways of saying things i found
it useful to learn the
i would call it neutral this form
hondas
okay so things happen at the end like
tomorrow
like ima now ikimasu
they don't even bother with we you they
you figure it out from the context
a lot of things happen at the end
i want
because i go or after i go so a lot of
things happen at the end in japanese
senses
uh the other thing is you know
so that these they're not prepositions
they're postpositions
uh
let's see uh
what would be another one
tokyo de de means at
so a lot of these little post positions
come afterward the good news in japanese
is there's no gender there's no number
uh the the nouns don't really inflect
you know whereas in russian if you buy
someone to someone of someone the word
the actual noun changes in japanese they
don't change so
all in all i don't find japanese to be a
very difficult language
uh
you the pronunciation is
fairly straightforward
the only thing is that you have to get
used to the fact that the sentence order
is different and
that's all i would say don't get in when
i see someone talking about
s-o-v-s-v-o i'm out of there fast
enough to say the word order is
different
and you have to get used to that and
don't try to resist it and just get used
to the patterns of how they say things
go back to the lists that you can find
that those resources that i suggested
the japanese the japanese page or take
him or whatever you find under japanese
grammar and spend a lot of time
listening and reading
and you will find that you know there's
no tones in japanese unlike chinese
um
it's a language where it's in a way
how would i put it whereas in french
everything is very clearly structured
and you have to put the words together
in a certain way to express yourself so
clearly and logically the japanese are
light like that they kind of sort of
like you know what i mean um ah that's
kind of the way the language gets put
together at least that's the impression
it's it creates with me and yet
within those
constraints people who speak it well
express themselves very elegantly it's a
different kind of elegance from the
french elegance or the mandarin elegance
or the italian elegance or the russian
elegance every language has its own
flavor and you have to kind of get used
to that flavor and enjoy it and not
resist it or find it strange you have to
get over that and just kind of
try to get it into you and get it a part
of you so
uh those of you interested in japanese
go to it there's lots of resources on
the web and of course you can also come
to link where we have japanese
i warn you that
because link has 21 languages it doesn't
operate the same for every language some
of the functionality works better with
some languages than with others
in japanese there is an issue where of
and ended chinese
of where the words split what is a word
and so
i would say 95 of the time it works fine
but there are sometimes some
inconveniences with link it doesn't
bother me i'm using it to increase my
vocabulary in japanese there's lots of
content there with both audio and text
and all of our functionality but it's
only one resource and there's lots of
other resources out there for those of
you who are interested
in learning japanese
and
don't hesitate by the way to let me know
what you would like me to
talk about or maybe you'd like me to
shut up i don't know bye for now